[music playing]
The roots of war lie buried
deep in the human past.
It has been a part of us
since before recorded history.
At the dawn of civilization,
our ties to the land
drove us to protect
what was ours.
We began to raise our children
not as hunters and farmers
but as soldiers.
Fear drove us to
fight to survive.
This primal fear
fueled the engines
of war, armies multiplied,
and our empires grew fast.
But war is not only
fought with soldiers,
it is fought with
inventions, the spear,
bow, iron, gunpowder, the bomb.
War pushes the
envelope of technology,
granting us God-like powers.
Tribal raids have given
away to nuclear missiles,
smart bombs, and cyber war.
Our instruments of
death have become
so powerful they now threaten
to erase humankind completely.
But is there more to
war than meets the eye?
Is it more than just
a plague on humanity?
War has transformed our
culture and rewritten
the map of the modern world.
Technologies have
revolutionized medicine,
transportation, communication,
changed how we live
and how we think.
This is the story of how
war makes us who we are,
how it shapes not just our world
but our destiny as a species.
This is origins.
[music playing]